thanks for tuning in to today's starlink
webcast Falcon 9 is set to deliver
another 51 starlink satellites to orbit
from vandenberg's base four spaces pad 4
East in California in today's Mission
Mark spacex's 30th launch of the year
and 229th overall missions
hello everyone my name is Chris Rhodes
and I am a structures engineer here at
SpaceX at T minus 4 minutes and 40
seconds the teams are currently tracking
no issues with the vehicle or spacecraft
weather is looking good and the range is
also ready to support liftoff time of
109 PM Pacific time
as we roll into the month of May we
wanted to give a shout out to all the
Asian American and Pacific Islanders or
aapi for all their past and continuing
contributions around the world we hope
you're all able to take some time to
recognize celebrate and learn more about
your aapi friends and neighbors this
month here at SpaceX we believe that in
order to achieve our goals of making
Humanity multi-planetary we need to
create an environment with teammates
from a diverse set of backgrounds with
varying perspectives and mindsets where
everyone can work in a welcoming
environment where all voices are equally
heard
in today's launch and the rocket on your
screen could not have been possible
without such a team
at T minus three minutes and 50 seconds
the clamp arms have fully opened beneath
the second stage and as you can see on
your screen the strong back has began
retracting away from the vehicle in
preparation for takeoff
as we head into the last few minutes of
our countdown it's worth noting that
there is a chance we may lose coverage
during today's Mission and if we lose
views and Telemetry we'll likely have to
end the webcast a little bit early but
we're crossing our fingers that all goes
well
and we are currently waiting for stage
one lock slope completion which will
wrap up in about 20 seconds
stage one lock code complete
at T minus three minutes Falcon 9's
first stage is now fully loaded with rp1
and liquid oxygen and we're now waiting
for completion of locks loading on the
second stage about 50 seconds from now
and once that's complete that will wrap
up propellant loading on the vehicle
in the white clouds that you see
circling around Falcon are completely
nominal and the result of our super
chilled liquid oxygen coming into
contact with the relatively warm Ambient
Air at the launch site turning the
liquid oxygen back to its gastro state
and again we're waiting for stage two
locks load completion which will wrap up
at T minus two minutes
stage two lock flow complete
Falcon 9 is now fully loaded with 1
million pounds of fuel and liquid oxygen
and it might be worth noting that we may
not get certain views from our second
stage camera today after takeoff but
we'll plan to show as many views as we
possibly can
the Boost you see on your screen is
flying for its third time today having
previously supported the space
development agency's trans zero Mission
and one starlink Mission an after
takeoff the booster will land on our
drone ship of course I still love you
we are currently waiting for Falcon 9 to
go into startup at T minus one minute
and we just heard that Falcon 9 is now
in startup running on its own internal
power
LDS go for launch
launch director has given us the final
go to proceed for launch let's sit back
and watch as Falcon 9 takes our 51
Starling satellites into space
T-minus 30 seconds
15 seconds
T minus ten nine eight seven six five
four three two one engines full power
and lift off of Starling go Starling go
falcon
Vehicles fishing down Ranger
MLB chamber pressure is normal
at t plus 30 seconds Falcon 9 has
successfully lifted off from space
launch complex 4 East at 109 PM Pacific
time
power and Telemetry are nominal
Falcon 9 is supersonic
just heard Falcon 9 is now supersonic
meaning that it is traveling faster than
the speed of sound
Max q and you just heard the call out
for Max q and this means that the
vehicle is currently experiencing the
greatest amount of external stresses as
it ascends through the Earth's
atmosphere that it will see during its
flight today
and we are about one minute away from a
series of events
Miko stage separation scs-1 and fairing
separation
Miko stands for main engine cutoff which
is when all nine Merlin engines will
shut down in preparation for stage
separation and during that point
pneumatic pushers will separate the
first and second stages and the first
stage will begin its Journey back to
Earth while the second stage will light
its Merlin vacuum engine making second
engine start 1 to propel our starlink
satellites their planned orbits and
shortly after the fairing halves will
separate and fall away from the vehicle
to later be recovered let's keep an eye
out for these events happening in pretty
quick succession about 15 seconds from
now
Miko
stage separation confirmed
and back ignition
fairing separation confirmed
Labs we can confirm Mikko stage step
scs-1 and varying separation and
although we didn't have views of faring
separation from the second stage we will
be attempting to recover both fairing
halves using our recovery vessel go
beyond both of the fairing halves flying
on today's Mission are flight proven and
are flying for their second time
both vehicles continue to follow nominal
trajectories
and there you heard that stage one and
stage two are both following nominal
trajectories and currently the first
stage is on its way back to Earth
towards our drone ship of course I still
love you and if successful this will
Mark our 190th overall Landing of an
orbital class rocket and the mvac engine
attached to the second stage is
continuing its burn which will last
another several minutes
and on the left side of your screen we
have views of our first stage as it's
making its way back to our Landing site
and the right side has our mvac engine
on the second stage which is performing
nominally
as you can see we have two out of
Falcons four grid fins in view on the
left side of your screen and they
measure four feet by five feet and help
guide our booster back to our Landing
site by actively changing the vehicle's
Center of pressure
and as a reminder starlink is a
satellite internet constellation
designed and manufactured by SpaceX to
provide high-speed low latency internet
to people living in remote and Rural
locations all around the globe the next
major Milestone we have coming up is the
beginning of our entry burn on our first
stage which is scheduled to occur around
t plus 6 minutes and 40 seconds
you also may be noticing white puffs of
gas from the bottom of our first stage
which is nitrogen from our attitude
control system which also helps us
control the vehicle's descent
both vehicles continue to follow nominal
trajectories
and again we're waiting for the
beginning of our stage one entry burn
around 10 seconds from now
stage one entry burn startup
and there's the call out for stage one
entry burn and stage one which we also
call the booster has ignited engines one
five and nine to slow it down for
atmospheric re-entry and this will be a
short burn lasting another 10 seconds
stage one entry burn shutdown
and you just heard the call out that the
entry burn on the first stage has
completed and the first stage used to
launch our 51 starlink satellites into
space today is flying for its third time
having supported the space development
agency's trans zero Mission and one star
one FTS has saved and one starlink
Mission previously
and coming up next we will have the
start of our Landing burn second engine
cut off and the landing of our first
stage stage two FTS has saved
stage one transonic
and you just heard the call out that the
first stage is now transonic meaning it
is traveling nearly the speed of sound
the second engine cutoff and the first
stage Landing attempt will happen in
quick succession so keep your eye out
stage two terminal guidance
stage one Landing bird
and there is confirmation that the stage
one Landing burn has started in
preparation for landing on our drone
ship of course I still love you which is
coming into view
stage one Landing leg deploy
stage one Landing confirmed and back
shot down
and we have a nominal orbit insertion
and Falcon 9 has successfully landed on
our drone ship of course I still love
you and this marks our 190th overall
Landing of an orbital class rocket
including Falcon 9 and Falcon heavy
missions and if you heard those callouts
we also had a successful Seco and
nominal orbital insertion with
confirmation of successful first stage
landing and good orbit from our second
stage that will wrap up our coverage for
today's starlink launch be sure to check
our social media for confirmation of
starlink deployment and as always thank
you so much for watching and we will see
you soon